i also have this area where
i'm i'm very so uh insecure about that
maybe it can what do you what are you
sorry what are you insecure about not my
height
and how tall are you in centimeters or
feet uh in feet would be ideal uh
in some ways it's 158 and feet i guess
it's
five foot three five foot four maybe
okay so
okay so you're a shorter dude so one of
my best friends growing up was five foot
five
and he would wear insoles in his shoes
that would give him about
an inch and a half lift just to make him
look taller in shoes but this guy had no
trouble slaying like he got
lots of girls he was my roommate so i
know for a fact
he got lots of girls but he got them
because
he looked like a pocket hercules he
looked like giga chad but shorter
right so guys like well you know um you
know i'm anxious about my height i'm not
tall enough you know what am i going to
do blah blah
blah okay you can't do anything about
your height okay there's limited things
that you can do spike up your hair so
you look taller
put insoles in your shoes so that gives
you a little bit of height but at the
end of the day if you're not very tall
be not very tall but jacked with [ __ ]
loads of money with great gain
and have a look you know to you that
women like there's there's lots of hot
women out there that are like
five foot one i don't date short women
because they're too small right so i
pass on them all the time
but there's lots of smoking hot women
out there that are five five foot one
that you can get with
at five foot four or five foot five you
know whatever your height is
but you don't worry about that which
what you got to look at is
how do i become that 10 out of 10
version of myself
make sense thank you sir okay read my
book do me a favor
read the damn book the unplugged alpha
it's on amazon get it
you